I put a lot of time into Starfield at
this point and I think my least favorite
thing is the lack of mini-maps somebody
from gamedashmaps.com has made a map of
New Atlantis I think the next episode of
playwatch listen which is a podcast I do
here with other game developers I'm
gonna ask the programmer that we have on
the show Mike Bissell why Starfield
doesn't have mini Maps like surely
there's some reason it was too difficult
I'd just love to know what that is and
if you like me are irked by that KIA is
a full star field map new Atlantis
things color-coded and number coded so
you can figure out exactly where you're
going it's got the residential district
Moss commercial and Spaceport I love
this just wish it were in the game at
least you can always reference it on
your phone while you play the game very
big thank you to gamedashmaps.com